[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend nach dem
Massaker das die Hamas am 7 Oktober
angerichtet hat ist das Ziel Israels
weiterhin die Terrororganisation Zitat
zu ichten und diese Vernichtung geht nun
schon seit 22 Tagen und seit gestern
werden diese Bemühungen aus der Luft vom
Boden und vom Meer aus intensiviert
allerdings auch mit etlichen zivilen
Opfern die Armee warf daher erneut
Flugblätter über dem Gazastreifen ab auf
denen die Palästinenser aufgefordert
werden unverzüglich in Richtung Süden zu
flüchten denn Gaza Stadt sei nun ein
Zitat Schlachtfeld Tim Krüger über die
wie Israel sie nennt zweite
Phase der Krieg geht in die vierte Woche
und in eine neue Phase laut israelischer
Armee greifen die Streitkräfte seit mehr
als 24 Stunden Ziele der Hamas mit
Bodentruppen im Norden des
gaserstreifens an man sei mit Infanterie
Artillerie und pioniertruppen
einmarschiert die Hamas hat Gegenwehr
angekündigt offenbar ist es zu schweren
Gefechten
gekommen heute gehen wir in nächste
Phase unsere Streitkräfte operieren zur
Zeit im Gazastreifen diese Operationen
sind begleitet von präzisem
Beschuss das israelische Militär hat die
Zivilbevölkerung dazu aufgerufen in den
Süden des Gazastreifens zu flüchten
parallel zur bodenoperation wurden
offenbar auch die Luftangriffe verstärkt
laut vereinter Nationen sein Internet
und mobilfunkeinrichtungen betroffen es
sei schwierig für Hilfsorganisationen
und die Menschen in gas zu
kommunizieren sie haben alle
Kommunikationswege unterbrochen keine
Anrufe kein
Internet sie haben alles unterbrochen
bevor sie einmarschiert
sind das Bombardement ist willkürlich es
wird niemand verschont egal ob Kinder
oder Erwachsene Frauen oder ältere die
ausgeweitete israelische bodenoperation
bereitet auch den Menschen in Israel
sorgen die um das Leben der mehr als 200
20 Geiseln fürchten die von der Hamas in
den Gazastreifen verschleppt
wurden ich habe große Angst der
Einmarsch ist das schlimmste was sie tun
konnten um einen Sieg zu erringen zuerst
müssen die Entführten um jeden Preis
freikommen ich mache mir Sorgen dass die
Geiseln während der bodenoperation
verletzt werden es sollte besser eine
Verhandlungslösung
geben die Regierung steht unter Druck
der israelische
Ministerpräsident traf sich heute mit
Angehörigen der Geiseln und versprach
alles für ihre Freilassung zu
tun wir werden jede Möglichkeit
ausschöpfen um sie nach Hause zu bringen
vor und auch nach dem Einmarsch mit
allem was uns zur Verfügung steht das
ist ein wesentlicher Bestandteil der
Operation in mehreren Teilen Israels gab
es außerdem heute Luftalarm wieder
schlugen Raketen aus dem Gazastreifen
ein am Abend hat das israelische eine
weitere Ausweitung der Bodenoperationen
angekündigt ja und für die israelischen
Truppen gibt es kein Rückzugsbefehl das
was wir da sehen scheint also die
angekündigte Bodenoffensive zu sein
fragen wir nach bei Michael bewerunge in
Tel Aviv offiziell heißt es allerdings
ja zweite Phase warum macht das einen
Unterschied das ist in der Planung so
vorgesehen gewesen dass die erste Phase
war erstmal das Grenzgebiet was die
hamassia gestürmt hatte wo lange noch
immer Kämpfer äh herumgezogen sind das
zu sichern und gleichzeitig mit
Bombardements die Infrastruktur der
Hamas zu zerstören und eben die zweite
Phase vorzubereiten die zweite Phase ist
nun die lange angekündigte
Bodenoffensive die jetzt offenbar
angelaufen ist der generalstfchef hat
heute abend noch mal gesagt diese
Bodenoffensive wurde schrittweise
ausgeweitet und klar bleibt dabei welche
Strategie welche Taktik dabei verfolgt
wird nur das Endziel ist klar am Ende
soll die Hammers zerschlagen werden
Netanyahu sprach ja heute Abend in einer
Pressekonferenz dann vom zweiten
Unabhängigkeitskrieg Israels nach
1948 was will er damit
sagen na ja das ist schon eine sehr
große geschichtliche Überhöhung oder
salopt gesagt vielleicht etwas dick
aufgetragen aber Netanyahu braucht ein
narrativ um
seinen eigenen Kopf zu retten bisher
haben alle Verantwortlichen für den 7
Sep für den 7 Oktober die Verantwortung
übernommen der Geheimdienstchef die
Armeeführung hat die Verantwortung
übernommen und auch der
Verteidigungsminister nur einer der
Premierminister hat noch keine
Verantwortung übernommen und er sucht
natürlich jetzt eine Möglichkeit sich
als den Führer darzustellen der
zumindest
äh den äh krieg jetzt zum Ende führt und
die Bedrohung die am Anfang stand
auszuschalten also das ist das narrativ
was er braucht und zweiter
Unabhängigkeitskrieg ist natürlich ein
sehr großes Wort dafür und ziemlich
viele Geiseln sollte er dann bei der
Offensive auch befreien ansonsten hätte
das wahrscheinlich auch weitere
Konsequenzen Michael bewerunge vielen
Dank für die
Einschätzung ja und an der Grenze zum
Libanon gab es auch wieder Gefechte
zwischen der israelischen Armee und und
der schiitenmiliz Hisbollah an anderer
Stelle wurde verbal gezündelt so warf
der türkische Präsident Erdogan vor
Hunderttausenden Anhängern auf einer
proalästinensischen Kundgebung Israel
vor Kriegsverbrechen zu verüben Israel
wiederum zog daraufhin verärgert seine
Diplomaten aus der Türkei zurück
vielleicht auch weil es nicht Erdogans
erster Afron war zuvor hatte er die
Hamas als Freiheitskämpfer bezeichnet
die Türke stuft sie nicht als
Terrororganisation ein anders dagegen in
Deutschland hier ist die Hamas verboten
hier steht kein politischer Vertreter an
der Seite der
Terrororganisation und hier stehen alle
Parteien unverbrüchlich wie es immer
heißt an der Seite Israels das wurde
heute auch noch einmal sehr deutlich
gezeigt auf dem CDU Landesparteitag in
nordrheinwestfahen wo es eigentlich um
die Wahl des Vorsitzenden ging Ralf
Goldmann Solidarität mit Israel nie
wieder ist jetzt steht auf dem Plakat
für den israelischen Botschafter das
Friedrich Merz und Hendrik wüst
mitgebracht hatten und die Delegierten
schwenkten israelische Fahnen der
Botschafter mit einer klaren Ansage in
Richtung Bundesregierung die hatte sich
bei einer Resolution der UNO zum Krieg
enthalten sich zu
enthalten weil man nicht direkt sagen
kann dass Hamas
für diese grausame Massaker
verantwortlich ist ist nicht
genug eine Botschaft des Botschafters
ganz im Sinne der CDU deren Hauptgegner
heute war die Bundesregierung der Bot
Friedrich märz beim Thema Migration
Zusammenarbeit an das Gesetz der
Innenministerin das schnellere
Abschiebungen möglich machen soll können
man mragen allerdings unter einer
Bedingung wirerden
nusmen einigermaßen sichere Gewehr dafür
gibt dass im nächsten Jahr die Zahlen
deutlich nach unten gegangen sind auch
Hendrik wüst nahm sich die Ampel vor
obwohl er selber an rehein und Ruhe mit
den Grünen regiert die irreguläre
Migration müsse dringend beendet
werden wer mehr Abschiebungen will der
braucht Vereinbarungen mit sicheren
Herkunftsländern keine sicheren
Herkunftsländer heißt keine Abschiebung
wir brauchen keine Nebelkerzen wir
brauchen handeln das wirklich wirkt
liebe Freunde und Freunde da geriet fast
schon in Vergessenheit dass hier zwei
aufeinander trafen die im Juni noch um
die Kanzlerkandidatur gebuht hatten für
parteiintern Zwist aber war heute kein
Platz eine Drohne Zerreißprobe sehen die
Delegierten jedenfalls nicht aber die
Gefahr an sich besteht nicht dass man
sich darüber zerreißt wichtig ist dass
es die Wettbewerber gibt innerhalb der
Partei die sich dann auch gegen einander
antreten mit einer Offenheit Streit ist
immer eine Gefahr streitende werden
nicht gewählt insofern ist gut
und gut zusammenarbeiten und sie haben
heute gesagt und gezeigt dass sie das
tun wollen geschlossen standen die
Delegierten am Ende hinter Hendrik wüst
der Landesvorsitzende wurde mit fast 97%
der Stimmen in seinem Amt
bestätigt gefühlt hat die Welt
insbesondere auch die mediale Welt nur
Platz für einen Krieg denn der in der
Ukraine findet seit 22 Tagen definitiv
weniger Beachtung daher sind die befür
der ukrainischen Regierung etwas
vergessen zu werden auch nicht ganz
unberechtigt keine Frage mediale
Aufmerksamkeit ist wichtig politische
und finanzielle Unterstützung allerdings
auch und die geht unvermindert weiter
beim Gipfel in Brüssel gestern einigten
sich die EU-Staaten ja auf neue
Militärhilfe aus dem Osten der Ukraine
berichtet Christian
sem die goldene rosensynagoge in nipro
hier lebt ein der größten und aktivsten
jüdischen
Landes die Ukrainer fühlen mit ihren
jüdischen Freunden merken aber dass der
russische Angriffskrieg wegen des
Krieges in Israel weniger Aufmerksamkeit
bekommt ich ma mir Sorgen und die Welt
sollte nicht vergessen was in der
Ukraine passiert während man auch nach
Israel
schauen wir verstehen dass zu viele
Konflikte auf einmal zu viel sind für
die Welt und wir fürchten dass jemand
anderes mehr Hilfe braucht als
wir im Schatten des Krieges setzt Putin
seinen Vernichtungskrieg gegen die
Ukraine weiter fort an der Frontlinie in
der Nähe von robotnie sind die
russischen Stellungen nur R und einen K
entfernt hier wird der Krieg vor allem
mit Drohnen
geführt unsere Angriffsdrohnen können
Soldaten und Ausrüstung treffen Drohnen
sind viel billiger als der Einsatz von
Artillerie ein Projektil kostet etwa 2
bis 3000 während eine Drohne 500 bis 600
kostet am schwersten sind die Gefechte
in der Ukraine momentan rund um die
Stadt avdivka im Osten des Landes die
Ukraine hat die Stadt seit 2014 zur
Festung ausgebaut und verteidigt sie mit
allen Mitteln die Gegend ist flacher die
russischen Truppen verfügen über keine
beherrschenden Höhen wie in der Endphase
der Schlacht und bachmut und deshalb ist
es inen viel schwieriger natürlich diese
Stadt einzunehmen oder vorwärts
zuukommen zudem haben die Ukrainer
dort die Gegend ähnlich dicht vermient
wie es die Russen zuvor im Süden gemacht
haben und dementsprechend hoch sind die
russischen Verluste der britische
Geheimdienst geht davon aus dass
Russland bei der Schlacht um avdivka mit
die schwersten Verluste in diesem Jahr
erlitten hat im Osten der Ukraine greift
die russische Armee weiter den Ort
adivka an und erleidet herbe Verluste
Sinn der Angriffe ist es ukrainische
Truppen zu binden die dann im Süden bei
der Großoffensive fehlen es ist der
Ukraine aber gelungen am Ostufer des
knipros Stellungen zu besetzen die
strategisch wichtig sind in nipro
versuchen die Menschen noch den
Spätherbst zu genießen trotz der
russischen Invasion und sie sagen wir
verstehen was in der Welt gerade los ist
aber bitte vergesst uns
nicht in vielen Städten sind heute
wieder Menschen auf die Straße gegangen
aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen und
damit beginnen deine Nachrichten Gundula
am dritten Wochenende inf Folge
forderten in London fast 100000
palästinensische Demonstranten eine
sofortige Feuerpause und ein freies
Palästina auch in Berlin haben sich
wieder tausende aus Solidarität mit
Palästinensern versammelt die
Organisatoren sprechen von 10000000
Teilnehmern laut Polizei mit einem
Großaufgebot im Einsatz waren es mehr
als 6000 Demonstranten die überwiegend
friedlich gegen Israel protestierten in
München gingen tagsüber bis zu 5000
Menschen auf die
Straßen Berlin wurde zudem durch
Protestaktionen für mehr Klimaschutz
blockiert hunderte Demonstranten der
letzten Generation störten den Verkehr
auf der Straße des 17 Juni zum
Brandenburger Tor auch klimaaktivisten
von extinction Rebellion beteiligten
sich der ehemalige
usvizepräsident Mike Pence will sich aus
dem parteiinternen Rennen der
Republikaner um das Amt des us
Präsidenten zurückziehen die Kandidatur
des
erzkonservativen Trump Kritikers kam bis
zuletzt nicht richtig in Schwung für die
Wahl im kommenden Jahr führt derzeit
Donald Trump das Bewerberfeld an in Iran
ist erneut eine junge Frau
möglicherweise nach einem Streit über
die Kopftuchpflicht gestorben wie Mascha
Amini im vergangenen Jahr nach einem
Monat im Koma erlag die 16-jährige ihren
Verletzungen sie sei in der U so
iranische Behörden in Ohnmacht gefallen
Aktivisten berichten von einer
Konfrontation mit
Sittenwächtern Schnitt hier der übliche
samstagservice die gewinnzahlen vom
Lotto sie lauten 1 5 7 26 32 38
Superzahl 3 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zf.de und im ZF
Text heute Nacht werden die Uhren wieder
um eine Stunde zurückgestellt und nach
dieser längeren Nacht wird das Wetter so
am Vormittag zieht Regen im Nordosten ab
im Südwesten kommt neuer auf Gewitter
können auch dabei sein Sonne nur im
Südosten teils starker Südwind 12 bis
20° bis Dienstag regnerisch am Mittwoch
dann mehr Sonne und nur noch selten
Regen bei sehr men 10 bis
20° heute sind allein in zwei Spielen
der ersten Fußball Bundesliga 14 Tore
gefallen 14 Sie haben richtig gehört das
und mehr gleich im Sportstudio mit Sven
Foss und direkt danach gegen 025 Uhr
gibt es hier wieder eine heute Express
mit Karsten parachollek und wir können
also wir haben es gehört eine Stunde
länger schlafen läer länger schlafen
also dann sehen wir uns hier morgen
pünktlich um 21:45 Uhr schönen Abend
tschüss ه